hôm nay thời gian mình cũng đang đắn đo
không biết nên để tiêu đề là gì bởi vì
mình nghĩ là kiểu bây giờ các bạn cần là
tập trung vào đồ án bởi vì cũng
cũng hết tuần này và sang tuần sau thì
mình bắt đầu kiểm tra đồ án các thứ thứ
rồi nên là mình không dậy kiểu dạng dạy
thêm kiến thức gì gì đó nữa mấy nữa mà
gần như là sẽ chỉ chữa cho các bạn là
chủ yếu thôi
thì hôm nay mình xin phép mình chữa cho
có bạn hỏi cả demo thêm full candle sau
đó thì mình sẽ tâm sự một tí cuối buổi
được không ạ bây giờ 8 giờ rồi mình nghĩ
là mình
bắt đầu dậy luôn cũng được sau đó thì
cuối buổi mình có thể tâm sự đúng không
ạ
Các nhóm nào có thắc mắc
có thắc mắc vì thì cớ họ để mình chữa
nhé
lần lượt đó là cái này thì mình ưu tiên
hơn mấy cái kia demo tính năng cái này
thì có bạn hôm hôm trước bạn ấy hỏi đó
là
tại sao em chạy hàm update of great
giống anh nhưng mà nhưng mà nó lại không
nó lại bị báo lỗi thì thực tế là là cái
này mình đây mình xin phép trả lời cái
câu đấy
Cái này là một cái rất là hay hôm mà
mình demo thì nó lại không lỗi thế nó
mới hay bởi vì ở hôm demo thì
nó lại kiểu Nó kiểu như này
đi Mở lại
mà không có cột ID tự động tăng thì các
bạn sẽ hiểu hơn
cửa hàng này bảng này các bạn thấy là nó
không có cột ID tự động tăng đúng không
ạ xem nhé xem nhé Đúng rồi bà này không
cột lại đi tự động tăng đúng chứ Thế bây
giờ giả sử mình cái này là chuỗi nhé
Mình có thể đổi thành bước từ cái gì
miễn là hai cái này nó hợp lý là được
hai cái này khóa chính hai cái này mình
đã để kiểu số Ok thì
hai cái này cùng là khóa chính và không
hề có một cột và cột Hòa chính là cột ID
ở là số tự động tăng đúng không ạ thì
khi mình chạy update Organ thì thì tên
của nó nó lên tất cả nó là kiểu dạng là
kiểu đây mình sẽ chạy thử cái test cứ
phải chạy thử thì các bạn sẽ dễ hình
dung hơn
test mình sẽ chạy đến controller thôi
kỹ hơn thì vào truy cập link nhé
học lập trình mình bắt đầu Cày từ đầu
tháng 8 Ừ cũng cũng khá là gần đây đúng
không
Cảm ơn bạn thật ra thì
dạy hay hơn những người khác thậm chí là
tôi cũng đang nhiều lúc tự ti có mình
tuy là mình tự tin thì mình mới làm được
việc nhưng mà
nghĩa mình tự tin là mình
làm được việc và dám thử nhưng mà tôi
không tự tin hẳn là mình giỏi hơn người
khác nên là Nên là các bạn đặc biệt là
các bạn
học online được cái lợi đó là có thể
tham khảo được rất nhiều nguồn nữa đúng
không ạ thì kênh của tôi thì chính vì nó
kiểu chất lượng nó cũng cũng có nhiều
lúc
cũng có nhiều lúc là là nó có vấn đề
theo kiểu là có thể khó hiểu hoặc hoặc
là hôm đấy tôi bị tâm trạng quá Có thể
tôi nói hôm đấy không đủ hay chẳng hạn
có vài hôm tôi xem lại video cũng có tôi
thường hay Xem lại video mà để mà đánh
giá bản thân thì hôm đấy Đúng là có thể
không ổn nhưng tôi cũng chẳng biết làm
như thế nào Ơ không muốn là tự nhiên tôi
kiểu bị lừa để mà không cũng bị lười một
phần và cũng không đủ thời gian và cũng
không đủ không đủ nhiều thứ để mà
để để mà kiểu quay lại hẳn một cái buổi
nào đó nên là sẽ có buổi mà tự tôi cảm
thấy là nó không đủ hay như mọi hôm
không đủ kiểu dạng dễ hiểu như mọi hôm
thì cái này thì gần như là hơi khó mình
bởi vì mình kiểu livestream chứ mình
không phải kiểu là quay lại video để mà
đăng lên để mình cắt ghép chỉnh sửa gì
cả
đấy
Nên là đây toàn bộ khóa học này nó miễn
phí nên là chỉ là một cái thứ để các bạn
có thể tham khảo và các bạn có thể biết
đến tôi để mà có thể hỏi đáp hay trợ
giúp gì đó cho các bạn còn còn để mà nói
là theo kiểu là học cái này thôi là đủ
thì tôi cũng khẳng định là cái đấy rất
là khó các bạn học cái này thôi để mà
đổi đi làm thì chỉ học Mỗi tội thôi và
thì nó khó kết hợp việc là các bạn phải
tự học rất nhiều bản thân là các bạn
đang làm đồ án hiện tại cũng thế các bạn
cũng phải tự học rất nhiều nữa thì mới
kiểu mới làm được cái gì đó chứ tôi dạy
như nào mà chỉ biết mỗi thế thôi thì gần
như không thể đủ
nghĩ là
Đây chỉ là một cái lựa chọn
một cái kiểu
một người nào đó truyền cảm hứng thì
chắc phải nghĩ là thế
tôi còn chưa Tạo mua đồ object language
ở đây mình sẽ có amax này mua đồ này
object
dễ hơn
không biết được
nó có tự động thêm chữ s ở trong cái tên
bảng hay không
thử ghét thử xem nhé
ghi lại đè lên là là
language
được rồi đúng không ạ Thì bây giờ mình
mình Bây giờ mình mới thử nếu mà giả sử
Giả sử là
khi mình chạy update opec
này
bản chất cái này sẽ truyền vào hai mảng
nó Tức là sao nghĩa kiểm tra
nó sẽ kiểm tra là thằng thằng bên này nó
sẽ ngoe theo ở bên này trước
cuộc sống như thế
bên này thằng Office có
ID là 1 và language ID một Nếu mà không
có thì nó sẽ tạo thêm hàng mới
tên là test Office
không có nằm trong philable đúng không ạ
thì mình một là mình sẽ kiểu khai báo
phi able 2 file báo tôi thường hay khai
báo vác được là trống như này cũng được
như này cũng được ám chỉ là mình sẽ cho
truyền hết vào tất cả các cột
update
nó cũng báo lỗi nhưng không phải không
Không
phải cái lỗi tôi muốn
5x 5x ID đang không Đúng Ok tôi xem thử
lại language ID nhé 68 đi truyền 68 ở
đây
giờ chắc là được ok rồi Insert thì là
được
tôi thử update đi
bây giờ nếu mà chạy lại thì nó sẽ phải
update cái này thằng từ từ test sang ASD
đúng không ạ Để thử này
nó sẽ bảo Cái lỗi này Cái lỗi này nếu mà
các bạn để kỹ câu truy vấn của mình sẽ
là update offect
bằng a SD ID is new Tại sao lại thế Tại
sao trường hợp này mình treo như logic ở
đây thì rõ ràng mình phải theo thằng này
Thế tại sao mình lại theo ID đấy
ghi đè lên cái Prime ban đầu
chết đấy nó mới hơn
nó không bị kiểu kia
Cuối cập nhật là bao giờ 4 tháng trước
Hình như ở đây đấy
ty nhưng mà Nếu giả sử sai tôi tôi cũng
cũng đọc qua cốt của nó rồi
code này từng đọc qua rồi mình cũng biết
cách sửa
chỉ cần u chết là được Cái này áp dụng
được cho là leo 8 Ok này rồi không ghi
rõ ở đây nhưng cập nhật 5 tháng 4 tháng
trước này chắc phải là 8 chứ không thì
cũ hơn được
xong mình sẽ yêu nó xong rồi khai báo
premikey theo kiểu này là được
được không sao tiếp theo là yêu cái này
đúng không ạ
cái truy vấn này hoặc khi lấy ra này thì
sẽ như nào đấy và mặc định nó cho cái
increementsphone rồi thì mình sẽ không
cần phải thêm cái kiểu là khai báo là
khóa chính là không tự động tăng nữa
lấy Ki ra thì nó sẽ biến thành mảng này
Đấy file fail file ở đây Hình như cái
này không dùng được cho update thì phải
Tại sao ông này mới chỉ có ghi đề một
file
để để xem thử nhé chạy thử lại cái này
là biết mà
trên công ty
có ngay đây mà
tại sao không được
cái này sẽ đổi lại đây nữa nhé
để xem thử nhé
chắc này
trả lại này
đó được
rút lại câu nghi ngờ
không được à tôi có tôi từng làm về cả
cái vụ
sót Delete các thứ nữa cơ cũng kiểu ghi
thẳng vào cái chết của nó ghi đè lên bản
chất cái này là cái chết nó sẽ ghi đè
lên những cái hàm có sẵn của thằng Ariel
là những cái hàm này này
là lúc mà lấy hóa chính ra như thế nào
hoặc là kiểu tìm theo khóa chính hoặc
đấy đấy Kiểu thế thì sẽ như thế nào
thường là đáng lẽ nó phải cập nhật nhiều
hơn chứ nhỉ
file ở trên công ty Lên xem thử
Tôi đang thấy cái này đang hơi hơi lạ
với lạ so với
cốt trên công ty
bằng nào trên công ty ở hai Cột
Bạn nào có hai cột
tôi lỡ không lưu lại không không lưu lại
cái
tôi copy về và tôi thêm một cái hàm nữa
Hồi đấy tôi cóp thêm được hàm nữa là hàm
này
khi chạy request khôi phục lại
file này xét key này rất key này thì ở
bên này nó là
ghétki này setti này ghét cát không biết
ghét Cát là gì luôn
nhưng mà nó không hàm Refresh
ghét Cát
cũng hay nhỉ Xem thử bay mới
Mấy cái cast sau đó thì nó sẽ kiểu
Converse hộ mình sang sang kiểu gì sang
kiểu khác thì
ở file ở công ty tôi lại không có nhưng
mà tôi đang để ý ở đây thì
còn đâu mình thấy khá giống đấy
cách code có thể khác khác một tí nhưng
mà mấy người này hiểu rõ bản chất của
cái hàm cần làm gì nên là cũng làm được
đấy đại khái thì tôi vừa chữa cho ông
mấy ông thấy là khi chạy update thì bản
chất là bây giờ nó sẽ là câu chỉ cần nó
sẽ như thế nào thì mấy ông Nếu mà Mấy
ông muốn xem thực sự là câu chuyện gần
như nào thường thì mấy ông lên nốt lại
cái này là
quay lót này
thường hai kiểu
thêm đoạn này đằng trước như thế này
và
đoạn này
để thêm cái này là được
một DD là 2 retail cũng được
kiểu select kiểm tra thẻ theo kiểu như
này Nếu mà có rồi thì sẽ mình sẽ cập
nhật
không cập nhật nữa chạy về thử thay đổi
nó xem nó thì sẽ là select này thấy nó
khác này thì bắt đầu cập nhật xong rồi
xét que theo kiểu như này không phải
quay theo ID nữa đúng không ạ Đó Ok chưa
tra nếu mà nếu mà khớp rồi thì nó không
cập nhật đỡ phải mất công ông ông nghĩ
cái cốt cốt Hồi trước của mình làm ấy
mình có thể kiểm tra xem là nó có thay
đổi hay không đâu mình mình lấy ra nhưng
mà mình vẫn sẽ cập nhật nó đúng không
Không hề liên quan mình không hề kiểm
tra xem là dữ liệu cũ nó như thế nào
mình vẫn chạy Hà update đúng không ạ thì
thực ra là thế thế thực ra không tốt
đúng không ạ
chạy update không nên chạy select ra
cũng được cách nhưng mà cách làm ở đây
nó sẽ là kiểm tra luôn kiểm tra xem Nó
tồn tại chưa Nếu mà chưa thì còn Insert
chứ không phải update
như thế Ok nhỉ
Bây giờ là tiếp theo là sẽ demo về cái
ru chết lẫn cả made này là một cái rất
là hay nhưng mà cái này mình sẽ chia sẻ
nhau chia sẻ thêm sau À đúng rồi các bạn
thì
hôm nay là thứ ba đúng không ạ thì như
mình bảo là Nói chung là hết tháng này
thì mình sẽ
lại nhắc lại một lần nữa thôi Hết tháng
này mình sẽ gần như là cốt các bạn phải
xong hết rồi nên là thứ bảy này thì vẫn
sẽ tiếp tục là tiếp tục là ngồi bảo vệ
thử đúng không ạ xem thử nói chung mấy
ông chuẩn bị tinh thần trước là thứ bảy
này mình sẽ bảo vệ thử thêm phát nữa còn
thứ năm thì có nhóm nào cần chữa hay
thắc mắc gì thì có gì cứ nhắn hỏi mình
nhé
Bây giờ mình sẽ thử demo cái phun
scandal
không biết có nhiều nhóm mà dùng cái
phunlen đời không nhưng mà tôi đang muốn
là ngoài việc demo cái này thì tôi dạy
thêm cho mấy ông về cái khái niệm làm
việc với bếp là cả api thì nó sẽ như thế
nào đấy bởi vì lâu tôi không Demo api
mình Lúc nãy quên hết rồi
xem cái demo trước đã để mô mình
năm trước
chất là mình sẽ
even click background
eventus
lâu tôi không làm tôi đang hơi quên
thông cảm
hình thức nào
mình trông Bắt đầu thấy quen quen
start là gì
[âm nhạc]
Dữ liệu trả về cần dạng di sản kiểu này
OK OK
để mình test nhé mình sẽ
mình sẽ
của nhé
[âm nhạc]
là đang như thế nào cơ
sao mỗi ví dụ này
lừa rồi
vào quên gần hết rồi
chúng ta đã có
hai cái
Ok
Mình sẽ bên này mình sẽ Return
views
lắm không làm nhúng CF của bên dưới rồi
bạn sẽ là mình gọi đến
sẽ có một cái router
ví dụ là ghét
hợp này như thế nào thì xem lại database
nhỉ
Nhưng mà mấy thời gian đấy chung nhau
thì chả có tác dụng gì cả
thì tôi cập nhật thời gian bên này thêm
một vài user nữa cập nhật thời gian là
được Ok vậy
cái này
cập đúng không ạ
có thể có thể là không cần em cũng được
luôn ngay Đây là thay đồ như này là as ở
đây sẽ là start
xem theo kiểu dạng ngày ấy thì cũng được
đấy nhá
Nhớ có một cái Menu ở đây Chọn theo Xem
dạng ngày cũng được
thể chỉnh sửa thêm
chỉnh thêm mấy cái ở đây để tôi xem nào
tính toán của gì đó đi
tôi đang không hình dung được mình sẽ
tính gì nếu các bạn thì thực ra nghĩ api
nó phải khó nhưng thực ra chỉ cần chạy
chạy như tôi vừa chạy code rất là ngắn
đúng không ạ cốt lấy ra xong rồi Kiểu
thế kỷ rim name luôn cả cái cái cột này
mà lấy ra
click even á xem nhé Ok Click vào đi
thêm mới cái gì đó đúng không
thể là sẽ thêm mới một cái gì đó cũng
được nghĩa làm chỉ là mình sẽ hiển thị
một cái để mình thêm
cũng được
nó để giống cái demo mà đúng không
hiển thị ra kiểu như này thì không ổn
nên là kiểu Thái thồ nhưng mà
ok khi mà select này
mình có thể
đầu tiên cho phép có thể select này đúng
không sau đó thì
Đây Rồi
solo.lodge cái thằng info này
để mình xem được là mình đã làm mình khi
mà mình bấm vào thì nó sẽ có gì xảy ra
đấy nó mình lấy được cái date này
cụ thể thời gian hơn ở đây trước khi
mình xem cho cậu dạng là là kiểu là kiểu
đây thì nó mới kiểu khác là xử còn như
này thì nó sẽ chỉ ra
kiểu không giờ ấy chứ nó không phải cụ
thể một cái giờ ở đó
thị giờ hiển thị
để tôi xem có những cái demo nào nữa
xem nhé
time like view này
được chọn đổi nhỉ
mình sẽ chọn được giờ
Dead click này thì nó sợ không đúng bởi
vì mình
là Thực ra nếu bản chất là mình ấn vào
đây thì nó sẽ tạo Ừ có thể nó tạo không
bắt đầu từ giờ này đi bắt đầu từ giờ này
xong mình sẽ có thể nhập thêm vào số giờ
nó sẽ chiếm Cũng được Cũng một ý hay
giả sử Giả sử Tôi có một cột create
bừa một cột vào nữa để cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung nhé và cột à Thôi dùng con cột
đi thật ấn nhé kiểu thời gian kết thúc
ấy Nếu thời gian bắt đầu có thể một kiểu
thời gian kết thúc kiểu kiểu thế
với Wechat đi
lên trên cung cũng được
sau đó thì mình
khi mình bản chất là mình sẽ có một cái
đít mua đồ đúng không ạ
mua đồ great à Không
booking đi đặt lịch sự thế muốn làm tính
năng đặt lịch
một cái form này
gió đúng không ạ
bao lâu ấy sẽ là
ra sân đúng không
gian kết thúc luôn được thì tùy mấy ông
hướng đến nó như thế nào
tiếp theo là
Thái thù đúng không
lên hàng ngày sẽ ra
mua đồ này sẽ là ở mình đặt tên là mua
đồ
Booking
ở nhà sẽ hiển thị ra đúng không ạ sẽ
mình sẽ có để xem à khi bấm cái này thì
ở cơ chế trước mắt như thế nào
bấm vào này chị nào nó hiển thị ra cái
để mà chọn thứ thứ giả sử chọn 3 tiếng
hay gì gì đó
nhìn nữa nhé
như này ta không Giờ còn nếu mà Mấy ông
xem theo tuần thì ông sẽ có cụ thể giờ
hơn đúng không ạ sẽ là cầu Nó là 3h30
thì bây giờ đầu tiên là bản chất cái
form này mình phải ngăn không cho nó
được sắp mít thì sẽ là sao đây sẽ là
cũng được
và mình sẽ dùng Isaac để để xử lý cái
form này
hoặc là như này
để xem nhé
ờm booking
Tôi xin phép mở
sau khi tách lên ngồi gõ code của đoạn
này nó recovery nó
[âm nhạc]
được gợi ý ngon hơn
bây giờ mỗi khi cái form này
mỗi khi form này Smith
chấm prevent để pho tất cả không ngăn
con chó sắp mít
Tôi nhớ là thế thử chạy thử nhé
sau đó mình sẽ gọi Ajax để mà sắp mít hộ
cái form này mình sẽ có router là
Sau đó mình trả về sẽ đi sân
sau đó thì những cái mình truyền lên
thì đợi từng tí những cái mình truyền
lên thì sẽ lấy toàn bộ những cái trong
form này thì mình sẽ dùng cái kiểu mình
làm đó là
đô la
bản chất cái hàm này lấy toàn bộ những
cái có ở trong form này và truyền lên
cùng nên là mình sẽ có thêm cái chrf ở
đây truyền kèm cùng tiếp theo là gì nhỉ
có cái info ở đây nữa mình sẽ
Tôi nghĩ là sẽ có một cái
input hai là hai đình ở đây đi
sẽ là
nêm sẽ là kiểu date tham và xử thế sau
đó thì mình có ID cũng là
Tết tham booking chẳng hạn
mỗi khi click vào thì cái cái này
cái Dead
Thực ra là boss xuống rồi gọi đến như
này luôn là hiểu rồi
cái trong form thì cái CSS này đương
nhiên nó có rồi thử nhé
3 này Alo này
Token
truyền à Đúng rồi ở ở đây thì nó chỉ
truyền ngày thôi nó không trên giờ bấm ở
bên này nó mới chuyên giờ
giờ thực ra giờ này đang hơi bị khó chịu
để tôi không biết được cacbon là
Converse được thằng này không chắc là có
xem nhé
Thì bây giờ mình lưu lại thì đơn giản
thôi sẽ lưu lại à
Đấy phải vai đếch
ông
đây là đang trong trường hợp thêm mới
nhé Còn nếu mà bấm click mà để mà để để
mà để mà sửa một cái gì đó còn phức tạp
hơn nữa nhé
Hãy nhớ một điều đó là Click vào sửa còn
phức tạp hơn thì bây giờ tôi có làm
trước cái thêm và tôi sẽ làm tôi hướng
dẫn luôn cho Mấy ông là bây giờ cũng
chẳng biết kể về cái gì Tra tí tâm sự
mỏng thêm tí nữa thôi Còn bây giờ tôi sẽ
chỉ thêm cho mấy ông à cũng tiện ăn liền
mạch nói tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông cả về vải để
chọn nha
mình cứ đặt tên vi-et ở đây thì thường
là tôi vẫn sẽ thêm cả admin xem nó xem
người đối tượng dùng là gì nếu mà nó
công khai là người khác cũng làm được
thì mình sẽ không nằm bên armin còn
không thì sẽ admin như thế này sau đó
thì user rồi booking giả sử như này vì
quét nhà chẳng hạn Nếu mà chuẩn hơn thì
nó sẽ là mình đang chạy đến Hàm store
booking thì sẽ store booking request Giả
sử Thế
sẽ có thư mục thư mục các thứ
à quên đó là make request đã thậm chí là
tôi hồi đấy là tôi từng tạo cái tắt rồi
thì phải tôi nói là
amrq luôn như này
hiểu là mic request rồi
sử ai cũng làm được này ru lại
đừng có ý nữa
mình sẽ truyền lên là mình truyền đuôi
Trần đúng không ạ duration bản chất là
nó sẽ cần là
string
mình sẽ chuyển thêm cái đã
tham
cũng là
request
ở đây sẽ ra
nhưng mà
mình cần convert nó ra Kiểu date trước
đã đúng không ạ Mình sẽ có
ray bằng cả cái đoạn này đúng không
sai
mới trống này Email
với tại Thái thồ Thế là xong
và nêm cũng thế luôn
dạ tiếp theo
theo kiểu đã khai báo kiểu này rồi
truyền kiểu Đúng rồi mình có thể khai
báo kiểu này nhé
chắc chắn ổn rồi Nó lấy ra Tránh trường
hợp mà ông gọi thẳng ra nó nó
chưa qua viber thì nó sẽ không Không có
Không phải lo
chuyển nó ra đây ra đi mình có ấp đúng
không ạ
Đầu tiên thì để mình phải xử lý cái bài
toán tiếp theo đây đã sẽ bằng request
này
input này
không Email nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm
nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
đương nhiên là ý anh là khi mà dùng cái
xếp này này tức là sao nghĩa là cái này
bắt buộc là phải cái xếp này sẽ chỉ lấy
những cái đã vài nét thôi
Nếu mà giả sử em quên khai báo ở trong
này thì khi mà em gọi ở đây nó sẽ không
ra nó sẽ không ra thằng này luôn Nếu mà
em quên không khai báo cái ru của nó ở
trong cái vidate hiểu không Nghĩa là một
khi em chắc chắn là vào đây của em có
đầy đủ rồi thì em sẽ có thể gọi như mọi
khi là kiểu input kiểu như thế này thay
đồ đúng không Hoặc là thậm chí là ghét
thậm chí là mọi khi làm thì có thể tắt
như này đúng chứ Nhưng mà nếu mà giả sử
mà em không chắc chắn được là là
nói chung để đảm bảo thôi là vice kiểu
em
chưa kiểm tra thì em có thể gọi sếp như
này rồi mới gọi như này nó sẽ thì thì
giống như em vừa thấy sửa trong thằng
trong hài của anh vừa rồi không có thằng
email ý nó sẽ biến thành lỗi ngay
hiểu không
như này thật bởi vì không Thằng này hơi
bị ngu một điểm đấy nếu mà gọi sếp cửa
nhà thì không gọi được sang hàng thằng
Dead như này được nữa Sẽ không có hoa
mai nhưng mà thôi kệ vậy
Nói chung là em giả sử em tự tin vai hết
ổn rồi thì ra không cần sếp lại được em
gọi thẳng như này cho nó không bám Cái
lỗi kiểu này cũng được
là array với
Ất này bằng để tham
copy không cần copy đâu như này thẳng
luôn còn thằng này nó là date thật Ất
Sửu Thế mình sẽ là thường là tôi sẽ gọi
copy hoặc như thế này để chắc chắn nó sẽ
không tác động đến hàng ngày sau đó thì
áp ở đây là
out
sau đó Thì
đory quét gọi điện bút
lấy
thì nó bị lỗi Đúng không
đây
không chạy được thì nó sẽ trả về luôn
cho thằng DS này thôi đã xong có thể vứt
thằng đuôi chân ở trên như này cũng được
đỡ khó hiểu nha
đồ Thái thụ
Email cũng bằng 2D
này
Mình sẽ vứt nó trong này như này xong
rồi đây sẽ Return
sushi
bây giờ bản chất là mình không có xuất
xứ Tôi chưa làm cái bộ sắp xếp thì mình
sẽ Return cỡ này
Sao tốt là mình sẽ chui đi
phone đi Ở đây sẽ là
có thể kiểu
lỗi này là lỗi
lên có vấn đề
lý nó sẽ là kiểu
sẽ có xúc xích
nhiên là mình sẽ cần là thêm vào trong
cái calendar
Tôi nghĩ là nếu mà làm như có đơn giản
thì chỉ cần thẳng gọi đến thằng kender
này xong rồi render
khi nó hay ở điểm là nó còn reload lại
thì kiểu Giả sử có hai
không hay admin cùng thêm cùng một lúc
thì có thể amin này không nhìn thấy đúng
không ạ render lại là một cái tôi thấy
khá là hay
gì đó Đương nhiên là cái mô đồ này cần
là đóng tôi nghĩa sẽ sẽ đóng sau khi
render Còn nếu mà giả sử mà sai thì mình
sẽ cần thông báo cái lỗi gì gì đó đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ để alard đi
nhằng lắm
Tôi sẽ có solo chấm lot cho mấy ông Xem
cụ thể
như thế nào lấy được cái message đó
tôi xem lại Tại sao hình như là tôi chưa
Đúng là tôi chưa truyền vào trong cái
phía bồ của nó nên là nó không kết được
cả đi
ông sẽ phải Wechat ở đây nhé
ok đầu tiên tôi có thêm lại nha
ba này
thành công nó chưa load lại để xem
không load lại cái calendar thì phải
nó không gọi lại thằng user này load lại
nó mới load lại còn
không nhận đâu
kiểu
4 này
chị nào chị nào giả sử à tôi
à À cái mua đồ này mình cần phải mình
cần phải
ngoài việc 2 nó đi thì thì cái form nó
sẽ phải
form nó phải kiểu reset nó lại nữa
reset from thì tôi nhớ không lầm là
bình thường thì có thể gọi hàm Trigger
như này cũng được
nhưng tôi nghĩ là như là nó một phát nó
reset được rồi
vào nữa mình sẽ phải gọi thủ công kiểu
này
lần nữa sai đi thì nó sẽ lỗi
nó vẫn thêm được này ảo nhỉ
unit nhé
thêm một cái nick đi
thêm cột nữa
mình thêm một cột nữa cho nó
cút sẽ là cột Email
mất rồi xóa một thằng đi này
chắc chắn là khi mà mình
thêm lại kiểu gì sẽ lỗi
rồi
lỗi thì nó để bắt được cái lỗi thì mình
feel ok rồi Tiếp theo là bây giờ
đây ở trong trường hợp mà mình truyền
hết booking feel Nếu mà truyền theo kiểu
dạng như này
thì
nó trả về cái Euro là kiểu không và kèm
theo 422 đúng không lỗi là 422
nó là thông qua cái thằng request này và
trả về là 422 thường là nó sẽ rid để
điều hướng đúng không ạ trong vidate
Nhưng mà khi mà nó nhận diện được là các
ông đang đẩy lên bằng kiểu Ajax kiểu xhr
kiểu này thì nó trở về là 200 hoặc 422
như vừa rồi nhưng nếu mà giả sử đối với
nhiều người không thích không thích kiểu
dạng là
kiểu trả vấn đề là 422 mình vẫn trả về
là 400 và thông báo lỗi của mình nó cũng
sẽ muốn giống hệt kiểu như này thì sao
thì vẫn mình vẫn sẽ tạo nên cái chết và
mình sẽ kiểu
xử lý khi mà lỗi thì cái đấy là cái hàm
chuyên sâu hơn của cái request này nhưng
hôm nay tôi thấy là thực ra hơi dài hôm
nay tạm tạm chỉ đến đây thôi
tôi chỉ có ý ông là mấy ông là tôi
thường hay tạm cái chết đó là kiểu để mà
thậm chí là tôi không muốn trả về cho
người dùng thông báo cái lỗi cụ thể là
Euro nó là như thế nào Như thế này cơ mà
tôi sẽ chỉ muốn trả về cho nó giống hệt
như mà cái mà tôi đang làm đó sau Tết là
fail và Messi là kiểu như thế này thôi
đấy thì sẽ làm như thế nào
chặt lại phải mở cốt ở công ty lên rồi
làm gì
nhỉ
request
như thế nào cơ
ông và tôi thường hay làm Nó kiểu như
này
chết nó ở thư mục này
luôn này
sẽ là kiểu
Euro
file date
à quên
http nữa
là tôi muốn quay về
ẩn đi này kèm theo trả về nó sẽ trả về
cái
export là cái mình đây này
you stress
Nó
Nó Magic là nun đúng không ạ bởi vì mình
đã kiểu ẩn cái lỗi đi rồi tiến Giả sử là
mình mình cũng yêu cái chết này nhưng
mình để không 02 không ẩn nó đi đúng
không
Thì sẽ ra lỗi ok chưa Và quan trọng là
nó sẽ là sau tết code sẽ là 400 cho nó
kiểu đồng bộ đấy và cũng sẽ có status là
fail và maxs như này các thứ thử Ok chứ
cách sử dụng stress kết hợp với việc
vào tủ 3D các thứ thứ như nào
Cái này khá là chuyên sâu ấy theo kiểu
là phải biết được cái hàm của thằng nào
leo khi mà xử lý lỗi nó là gì
đè lên cho nó hôm nay chắc là cái để tôi
cần đề cập nhiều nhất Chắc là liên quan
đến cái chết này hiểu thế
khẳng định luôn là không phải ông nào
cũng kiểu đã động sâu vào đến nay nhưng
mà để tinh chỉnh mấy cái kiểu như này
thì
gì mấy ông muốn kiểu cấu hình config
thêm cái gì nữa tôi sẽ hướng dẫn thêm
cho tôi cũng là người hay mò thử thử như
thế Kinh nhỉ buổi mai chắc cũng này thôi
chẳng còn thắc mắc gì đâu nhỉ
để buổi hôm sau nếu mà
nếu buổi hôm sau không có nhóm nào hỏi
gì cả thì chắc là tôi sẽ chữa cho mình
không cả phụ là khi tôi sẽ thử thử thì
bấm vào cái này nó có thể sửa được không
các thứ mà mình còn kiểm tra điều kiện
các thứ ru rúm các thứ thứ nữa kiểm tra
sửa các thứ như thế nào
Hôm nay chắc là tạm ngừng tại đây không
nhỉ
Hôm nay tâm sự nhỉ Thôi không mày cứ tạm
ngừng lại đây có gì để hôm sau tâm sự đi
Chào mấy ông nhé